Traductor: Federica Bruno
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En la primavera de 1947, seis
exploradores escandinavos
observaron un extraño fenómeno
mientras cruzaban el océano Pacífico.
De alguna manera, pequeños calamares
conocidos por vivir
muy por debajo de las olas,
seguían apareciendo
en el techo de su barco.
La tripulación estaba desconcertada,
hasta que vieron a los calamares volando
casi 50 metros sobre el mar.
De regreso a tierra, las personas
apenas podían creer a los exploradores.
Parecía imposible que criaturas marinas
sin alas o huesos pudieran volar,
mucho menos recorrer la mitad del largo
de un campo de fútbol.
Pero durante las siguientes décadas
empezaron a surgir más reportes.
Los marineros describían
a calamares voladores
que iban al ritmo
de los motores de los botes.
Los investigadores reportaron
calamares en cautiverio
que escapaban de sus tanques
durante la noche.
Y desde que las cámaras se generalizaron,
los navegantes por fin pudieron capturar
las pruebas de estos
cefalópodos voladores.
Pero, ¿cómo y por qué
estas criaturas marinas
suben a las alturas?
Mientras que solo unas cuantas
especies de calamar
han sido grabadas
emprendiendo vuelo,
la mayoría de los calamares
atraviesan el océano
de manera similar.
La parte externa del cuerpo del calamar
es un enorme tubo de músculo
llamado manto.
El agua entra al tubo
a través de pequeños orificios
en la cabeza del calamar.
Después, los músculos mantienen
estos orificios cerrados
y el calamar bombea con fuerza el agua
a través de la base de su cuerpo.
De hecho, esto hace al manto
un propulsor miniatura,
impulsando al calamar a través del agua
a 10 km/h.
Los calamares respiran
con este mismo proceso.
Las branquias del calamar
se encuentran dentro del manto
y desvían el oxígeno del agua
que pasa impulsada a través de ellas.
Con las branquias llenas de aire
y el manto lleno de agua
el calamar puede aventajar
a sus depredadores
y perseguir a su presa.
O, en el caso de algunas especies,
pueden atravesar la superficie del océano
e intentar un vuelo épico.
Sin la resistencia del agua,
la aceleración de un calamar
es la misma que la de un automóvil
yendo de cero a 100 km/h
en poco más de un segundo.
A velocidades de 40 km/h,
el calamar puede generar rápidamente
una elevación aerodinámica.
Pero para mantenerse en el aire
necesita algo parecido a las alas.
Afortunadamente,
nuestro cefalópodo volador
tiene un plan.
Los tentáculos del calamar
son hidrostatos musculares,
es decir que el tejido
puede mantenerse firme
mediante la tensión muscular.
Al extender sus tentáculos
en una formación rígida,
el calamar los transforma en
estructuras flexibles en forma de alas
que estabilizan su vuelo.
Al lado opuesto de su cuerpo,
dos aletas que usa normalmente
para nadar suavemente
tienen un nuevo propósito
como segundo conjunto de alas.
Y al doblar estas aletas hacia abajo,
el calamar se vuelve aerodinámico
y se sumerge de nuevo en el océano.
Ha habido muy pocas observaciones
como para determinar cómo es
la trayectoria de vuelo característica
de un calamar.
Con base en su velocidad de vuelo,
un calamar de 10 cm,
hipotéticamente, podría lanzarse
a 6 m sobre el agua.
Pero por lo que los científicos han visto,
los calamares voladores
tienden a deslizarse a un nivel bajo
manteniéndose cerca de la superficie.
Esta trayectoria permite a los calamares
cubrir, horizontalmente,
la mayor distancia posible
durante un vuelo normal
de varios segundos.
Esto también hace que le resulte fácil
volver a sumergirse en el agua
en busca de más combustible
o para escapar rápidamente
de las aves de presa.
Pero ¿por qué vuelan los calamares?
Las principales teorías sugieren que volar
es un comportamiento de huida,
pues los calamares voladores,
por lo general,
parecen estar huyendo de un barco
o de un depredador cercano.
Otros investigadores creen que su vuelo
puede ser una estrategia
de migración para ahorrar energía,
porque se requiere menos energía
para moverse rápidamente por el aire
que a través del agua.
Sin embargo, es posible también
que el aprender a volar
sea una parte fundamental
para sobrevivir durante la adolescencia.
Lo calamares más jóvenes y pequeños
pueden volar, potencialmente,
más rápido y a mayor distancia
que sus parientes más grandes.
Y como los calamares adultos
tienden a canibalizar a los jóvenes,
volar por encima de las olas, puede ayudar
a asegurar que estos calamares jóvenes
vivan para volar otro día.